like I always wonder with with girls you
always hear about girls to blow up they
get kind of diva-ish is it hot does this
Iggy still hit you back on the like you
know you hit up Iggy you get the instant
text backer time investment that's not
even that's not a problem you know it's
a big bid to see to think about Iggy is
she was she's like she was before all
this you know I'm saying she's the same
way she's always been you know he you
know sand is just uh it's a little more
it's a little more amplified a little
more stuff in the writer now I mean you
know what god bless whoever has to feel
her either I don't even know any see
that's not a part of that's not a part
of the business I have to really deal
with writing on zan I'm on a different
how can I say I have a different duty I
want to ask you man um I know that a UN
game had a little thing that went up on
TMZ it wasn't like last one right my
thing is like I feel like in hip-hop man
there's like there's a lot of associates
but not a lot of like real like like
artists that are truly friends with each
other like who are like two or three
cats that you would really consider like
true friends in the game Oh Nellie
well you and Nellie could you know know
he did he did take some awesome shots on
ESPN about boy Mary's on whoo man y'all
start talking about clouds after eight
o'clock man you'll have to come many
nervous that uh young jeezy
um
killer Mike killer Mike yogurt date uh
about the money remix he did idea it was
official or not yeah it's new
productivity but it's in whoa yeah you
brought it to me uh he brought it to me
in that old man you know do your thing I
think it's crazy
mmm-hmm so killing my Jeezy and uh her
Natalie Ferrell
yeah how did the UH Lord Lysol like you
always read me to do it you've always
been like a huge superstar Chevy
commercials movies everything did you
feel like that song kind of like did
that kind of put you in a different
place oh you think like wobbler life is
like
one big assault I'll be doing hit
records man will you tell me I know that
but that was like yeah no I did my
little just to bleep hey this is rare
everywhere I'm a dear soldier with
doesn't each other
I know I know you've done a lot of big
Ram look lies by Mike now I'm just
amazed eros after after the record I
mean a man's ear Olivia oh yeah of
course
okay what are then sip a deal sipping
tea Lindsay she won't be able to do out
man
not everybody from Young Jeezy to try
the truth to Betsy here watch the duck
Nipsey Hussle big country ke.gypsies on
the album yeah I had problems will okay
I got some West Coast flavor on Rick
Ross for a dream Lucy got a lot of stuff
going I'm assuming a stuffed boy who
produced the the nipsey joint our DJ's
own okay his in problems on a separate
record yeah separate League of stars
beat League stars along with problems
and my god
I still man can't wait to get out and uh
what does he fish release they let
everybody know well you know we're gonna
do this now don't tell you around and
about when it's going to come round and
about what do we around it about expect
your check okay I want everybody to
check your astrology calendars okay
there's a section of the calendar that
is sectioned off for the libras all
right the scales that balance the
universe we go drop some when Libra
season all right
my cousin Libra you know what I am I
believe yeah that's what we're gonna do
for the leap for sure
Libra season indeed somewhere Libra
season August 25th the new TV show is it
like hard man cuz I know everything you
do is so publicize like if you have a
fight with your girl everyone knows
you know I'm saying but you're also on
TV now and you got the reality show is
it ever frustrating like having to kind
of live your life in front of everybody
oh really man I don't see it like that I
mean I just did I'm just living my life
I don't know what are they watching
tonight right you don't really pay
attention all yeah not really man
you know I'm saying I just I deal with
what I want to publicly you know and and
and and the rest I don't have to deal
with and if I want to I get the seventy
like it
now ti her Titans back on her on her
music - she put out a single lot of
girls loving it are you involved with
any tiny music are you like kind of like
the the filter where she plays you
records or I have an control I have
authority over absolutely nothing so
anything he comes off in tiny that is
hurt she is and she operates individual
she got it but later question about the
star of the ti TV experience uh-huh his
name is major yeah
uh his major getting his own show on TV
come on they don't want to be bothered I
fir made you want to play this video
game and go outside made you don't want
I mean it means no yep clean out the
kids they want to actually you know I'm
saying
really really makes any grow if you want
to work on a torch though I want it I
feel like you've been a dude who's
historically uh been like I don't want
to say quick - but you've you've ended
some careers little flip young-sam like
you've always kind of had you like old
man give some further yah-yah-yah-yah
but now I feel like a couple cats and
kind of haven't tried I think I think a
few cats who kind of tried you like
since you've kind of been on top you
don't saying you've kind of just kind of
let it let it go per se as far as on wax
um is that something just were growing
up that's the end of meteo that's the
end of the team I'm sorry you were
saying
I was saying you know I think maybe like
I'm serious trap music tip with might
have maybe you know got invaded into a
couple more be
last few years is that something you
kind of just kind of was growing up
something you kind of just you know now
they grew of it up yeah I see a pity
still me I'm joking I'm joking man now
they I mean man for real
something's worth of attention man some
things just you know you understand that
you know I'm saying you got cats at the
bottom they're just you know doing a
thanks for attention I'm Sam um I think
you know nothing to speak with my words
I speak my soul with my actions 100 son
I let my actions dictate you know I let
my actions you know dictate the flow of
the conversation that's what's up
you know I don't want to talk about what
I'm gonna do them talk about what I have
done you know same respect that is there
anything I won't talk at all I'm going
to do so is there anything paperwork t.i
if you had to give some advice - I'm
serious ti one piece of advice if you
could give advice to that guy you know
what would it be just kick back and be
patient is coming it's coming
don't worry o is coming